[Applause]
chaos and kiev as thousands jostle at
the train station desperate to leave the
ukrainian capital
soldiers reportedly fired into the air
to disperse the crowd
we've been trying to live all day from
the morning but as you can see that's
unrealistic
russian troops are edging closer with
explosions heard around the city earlier
this apartment block was hit
yes
i was sleeping there was a sharp
explosion and i was thrown three meters
from the room i was in into the corridor
the glass shattered there were sounds
coming from the street i got scared and
started crawling on the floor oksana
gulenko made it out alive while
emergency workers went door to door
searching for victims
and as russian tanks rolled into the
city below ground people crowded into
metro stations exhausted and uncertain
about what's to come
the shelter in our building is not as
far underground as the metro station
that's why i think it's safer to come
down here
at least a hundred thousand people have
been displaced by the fighting
but the united nations says the number
seeking refuge outside ukraine could
reach 5 million
we had to leave behind everything our
whole lives work
it's a terrible feeling to leave your
home you can't imagine how i feel now
these families have crossed the border
into hungary hoping it won't be too long
before they can return
there are long queues at all the banks
and the atms have been emptied there are
throngs in the shops and you pretty much
can't buy anything anymore and even
paying by card is not possible because
some banks are not working and there are
hour long queues at petrol stations
further along the frontier in poland hot
food and drinks are being served with
temperatures hovering around zero
degrees celsius
some people walked 18 hours to get here
many with young children
escaping what rights groups say are
indiscriminate attacks by russian forces
[Music]
ukrainian national anthem as she clears
up after the attack
despite the devastation
an air of defiance remains
alexia o'brien al jazeera